[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos and for real
for real what is happening Chris Evans
is on the podcast today Chris Evans he's
in the new Apple TV movie ghosted which
is hilarious and wonderful he's in
knives out he's in Captain America ever
heard of it ever heard of it I also just
rewatched the gray man which he's in
with Daddy Gosling and he's incredible
he's so funny he's so Charming he's so
talented and in this conversation you're
about to hear he's so intelligent deep
uh and Brilliant I mean what a thrill
we've never met IRL uh and we were so
happy to sit down and chat for the first
time uh that you're about to hear this
is our first long hang after a few
exchanges online and it went so well and
I'm so happy to share it with you uh go
watch ghosted on Apple TV just anything
anything Chris Evans isn't go check it
out and if you'd like to see me uh live
I'm currently on tour thank you first of
all to everybody we sold out Royal Oak
Michigan which was so fun Cleveland Ohio
was so fun coming up next is New York
New York haven't been to New York New
York since 2019. it's going to be great
to be back then Ridgefield Connecticut
then I'll be in Denver St Louis Raleigh
North Carolina and then Salt Lake City
all of those are available at
petehomes.com I love this new hour I'm
so excited we actually just filmed it
but I'm still touring it because the the
special won't be on Netflix until
October and I shot it and it was so fun
and I'm going to keep touring it because
I'm in love with it I love performing it
hope you can see it petehomes.com for
tickets speaking of uh my special when I
you know obviously you're going to tape
your special you want to look good this
is 100 real I wore no doubt my perfect
jeans this episode is brought To Us by
our friends at the perfect Gene and
evidence that I legit love the perfect
Gene not only when I want to feel good
because they are the best pants I've
ever owned they're soft but it's like a
soft secret it's two percent spandex 2.5
round for extra comfort and movement
that your man Parts require but they
also look like designer jeans they have
the best washes and the best cuts and
they look incredible and they're made
from the best quality sewing techniques
and materials meaning I have all my
jeans are perfect jeans and they never
need to be replaced and they move
they're flexible they're soft
comfortable pants they're not yoga pants
they are jeans but they stretch so your
nuts ain't crushed thereby providing the
only true home for your bone with
specialized washing for your jeans so
they feel literally as soft as a baby's
butt you might even forget you're
wearing pants and as I said they're
constructed utilizing the best quality
materials and sewing techniques to
provide you with a product that is built
to last and they're not khakis although
they do make Gene khakis and those are
my new favorite they also make hoodies
which are my new favorite hoodies I'm
obsessed with their hoodies I'm obsessed
with their t-shirts I wore one of their
white crisp t-shirts for my special as
well and I wore their athletic cut dark
blue uh dark blue dark blue great jeans
I wore these dark blue jeans for my
special and they look incredible so
check them out I absolutely love them
and I reached out to them to sponsor the
show and that's how we got here so the
perfect Jean for Perfectly Imperfect men
20 off when you use code weirdo at
checkout liberate your your lower limbs
with the one and only perfect Gene
whether you're working with lemons or
lentils a three leaf clover or a big old
honking eggplant the perfect Gene has
you covered you can look good and feel
good take a peek at the perfect
gene.nyc that's
www.theperfect j e a n dot NYC news code
weirdo for 20 off at checkout support
your body look good and support this
show alright everybody hope to see you
on the road in the meantime enjoy this
chat with the incredible the
incomparable
Chris Evans get into it hello
shaboopy
what fun this is so cool man thank you
for doing this
to me yeah it's great to meet you I'm
I'm so excited where are you right now
I'm in Massachusetts this is home base
oh really yeah where you maybe you don't
want to say where I probably won't uh
you live on Plymouth Plantation I I've
known this about you that's right
original colony [__]
I actually
um I'm gonna try I almost said dude I'm
gonna try and curb my dudes but I was
doing a little research obviously I'm a
huge fan of yours but I didn't know you
were from Boston did you know I'm from
Boston are you really yeah well I'm I'm
born in Boston but I'm from Lexington
get the [__] out of here that is crazy
born in Boston as well
yeah Brigham yeah Hospital man yeah and
I lingered there for a few years so I
might have been nearby when you were
born isn't that wild Oh I thought you
meant you lingered at the hospital for a
few you weren't quite right no I did no
I did that's what I meant it was a joke
yeah maybe I just kind of was like I
have a feeling that an actor I'll enjoy
is going to be born any minute now
that's crazy that's Lexington when did
you leave there
I was in uh Lexington until I started
doing stand-up when I was in uh college
is that right yeah college so I
performed in Faneuil Hall at the comedy
connection did you ever go there no I
didn't so you said you had yeah you you
don't want to go there grew up in
Lexington you're from Massachusetts I
went yeah my you I liked you I well
that's what's funny is like people from
Boston do tend to like I feel like
attract each other and there's something
going on my I went to school in
Cambridge though not Harvard I went to
grade school in Cambridge so like
Harvard Square that was like my that's
where the Hang was going like Newbury
Comics
Newbury Comics right no get the [__] out
of here really I love Newberry Comics
before the Anarchist Cookbook remember
the Anarchist Cookbook before we had the
internet it was that black book that
told you how to make Napalm and stuff it
was like it was like a printout of all
the naughty bits of the internet before
the internet and all the t-shirts I
still have there's a t-shirt of Richard
Nixon and Elvis when they met in the
Oval Office and they sold this at
Newbury Comics my friend Aaron just gave
this to me and we used to love it it's
just a picture of them shaking hands and
underneath it it says we're dead and
that was that was just that's that's the
humor of Newbury Comics so it's both
these [__] that's your gifts
you ever go to I mean the the Natick
Mall or no it was a Framingham mall
right because the Shoppers World I was
at Burlington Mall you were a Natick
Mall yeah no I was well Natick Mall had
the outdoor thing it was it was Shoppers
World it's where you'd go to see Santa
in the winter but then I think no the
big one was in Framingham right next to
AMC
it's funny that you say that man because
when I I saw Goodwill Hunting at in
Woburn the Woburn Cinema and and you can
see that from 128. so when I'm in
[__] Woburn I drive by and I look at
that theater with such fondness because
that was the movie I'm sure it was for
you too or I I don't mean to project
onto you I just mean kids from Boston
that wanted to be in Show Business I
look at Woburn the I think it's an AMC I
don't know I look at that as like not
Hallowed Ground but that's a special
place for me because remember when you'd
see a movie and you'd like go for a
drive afterwards
you had you couldn't you couldn't go
home you had to like Cruise a little bit
in my friend John ireli's car we just
drove and thought about our lives and
how badly we wanted to be Ben and Matt
did you have that thing
typically to the soundtrack of good boy
hunting what was it Elliott Smith yeah
reflective yes pretty depressing yes of
course go inside too yeah and were they
again not to project but for me seeing
kids they went to ring and Latin you
know they were yeah I guess if we can
call ourselves townies I don't know if
that's just Charlestown I've never known
exactly but we're from that area seeing
those guys kind of make it in film did
that have an impact on you of course I
mean not only did I love that movie but
I mean they they set the bar so high
right out of the gate you know what I
mean they weren't just in a great movie
they wrote the [__] thing right they
wrote the [__] building Oscars you
know what I mean you're like all right
take step by step guys you don't have to
just finish the race yeah and they took
their [__] moms to the Oscars yeah
yeah which is like I mean come on you're
out showing all of us Boston kids yeah I
was so I remember the first time I met
Ben Affleck I was auditioning for um
what was the not not the town uh Gone
Baby Gone and I remember it was just a
general
um
and I showed up and I I parked outside
came inside walking down the the hallway
looking for this one office building
and I passed a room and I heard someone
go uh there he is and I was like that
was bad that was bad and I can I cruise
back in I I shook his hand and just
right away I just got so [__] nervous
just yeah uncontrollably he's a big guy
you know and I just yeah
and Rod shoulders his shoulders are so
broad that's the thing you just look you
know I mean he's intense he's in himself
and I yeah further from myself and I sit
down in a chair that [__] rocks and
swivels so I'm just like doing all this
[__] and as soon as I sat down the first
thing out of my mouth was uh ah nice to
meet you
am I gonna be okay when I parked and he
was like where'd you park and I was like
at a meter and he said did you put money
in the meter and I said Yup he's like I
think he'll be okay I was like yeah Rob
let's just dive in and it just it
derailed I just like I couldn't make
sentences and I just got Starstruck yes
yeah see I this is what not to butter
your bread too hard but we got in touch
yeah please why not I mean why not love
is free you know what I mean like it's
it's free to give people good feelings I
don't know why we're shy about it are
you um
I'm an over gusher though like [__] this
is how this happened I reached out to
you I was like you know what you're
great you're the best
and I told you when the ghosted trailer
came out because I was truly impressed
and and I watched the film since and I
loved it and I loved you in it and
comedy action is so [__] hard I'm not
I don't want to name names I've just
seen some of the greatest ever go like I
I can do this and I can do that let's
put them together and it just kind of
you know it's like a chair that that
swivels and and it's just very hard to
navigate I'm with you like give it up
but when when I hear you talking about
being awkward in front of Affleck and
stuff there is something about you
that's vulnerable I'm not trying to be
weird I'm just saying that you're you
know strong Marvel guy but there's
something
shut up shut up you [__] door yes
come on
this is hat there he is he
made it in the frame that was like
perfectly framed up to catch him running
outside
um I told Val to keep our dog I was like
please keep Brody quiet just just for a
little bit anyway what I'm saying comedy
relies on some vulnerability so when I
hear you say you were nervous meeting
Ben and the chair is weird that's the
place that comedy comes from so while I
know most of the world sees you as you
know Captain America like if we went to
the Mall of America that's that's what's
gonna happen you know what I mean like
that's the thing yeah but I'm I'm
picking up on what you're talking like I
also saw you talking with Scarlett
Johansson for that actors on actors
thing and you said something that I
really related to which is it takes you
a couple days to get comfortable on set
like and I was like oh my god the guy
that shows up when I do something the
guy that shows up on day one I'm just so
quiet and not sure what the vibe is and
don't know how to play it and then three
days later I'm picking people up and
flipping them around and you know
do it
put a pin in it
tell me it takes me
you must know this family this is one of
I've never not had this
about a week after the scene is over
that's when I figure it out that's when
I'm like Oh my God I just unlocked it
yes what I doing on the day yes it's
such a heartbreaker as many times as you
think you you know looked at it from
every angle yes um it doesn't make sense
once it's too late how about this
sometimes you confuse being in a great
mood with a great performance like you
think because you were feeling good that
it must have but like you realize how
you're feeling has nothing to do with
what's being captured and sometimes I'm
like that was the greatest thing I've
ever done or simultaneously or I was
depressed or kind of low that day and
I'm like so therefore the performance
must have stunk I didn't feel great what
does that have to do with anything yeah
well even I mean
acting is just this forever prism to me
you always can look at it from a
different angle and find new way in and
and it always feels a little off but but
there are times
I mean I've done films where I've I've
you know a little shoot a scene and and
you know cut and I'm like listen nobody
can tell me that that was not I was in
it I was in it I was listening I was
reacting I was present there's no way
and then you watch it back and it's just
not it because in a way you're like oh I
didn't know they were gonna
shoot it like that although the music
you was gonna you know and again you
shouldn't cut your cloth according to
those other elements you should just be
trying to tell the truth but the problem
the bottom line is it's a collaboration
it doesn't hurt you to kind of be aware
of all these elements and maybe lean One
Direction or the other that that you
think just telling the truth is enough
yeah um and not always it's kind of all
you are you saying that like you're sort
of at the mercy of the edit and the and
the choices that they're making well to
some degree but also you have to be as
an actor at least I think aware of also
what the scene needs it's not just about
your own individual truth my only job
like it's also a matter of like listen
that was sure truthful but there might
have been a better way or a more
interesting way or a more Dynamic way
sometimes your own personal truth or
even the character's truth God this is
drifting pretentious but but sometimes I
love it sometimes it's just not enough
sometimes you almost kind of gotta like
push something in a direction that
doesn't feel I feel stiff to all of a
sudden actually like unlock something or
I get it can I can I interject to this
it's like to see if this shapes it for
me or you
when I hear I hear you let's go for the
truth and then like you've worked with
people like and this is not a clickbaity
show it's not a star nobody's going for
that so I'm saying this genuinely you
worked with like someone like Robert
Downey Jr who is like intensely
interesting so it seems to me we can't
know he's not just going for like what's
the most honest way to react he's
actually adding a little Razzle Dazzle
if that makes sense yeah I mean this is
where it's so tough because we all have
our own insecurities as an actor and
then you look at people who are
brilliant and you try to measure the
distance between you and them and wonder
listen is it just because some people
it's like athletes some people can just
jump through the roof they have an
unbelievable 40. they're just gifted
some people are innately interesting
they can sit there and read a book and I
watch you you lean in yeah other people
have a a face that isn't as interesting
and it really might not have anything to
do with
the commitment to the truth that's
actually going on inside them I don't
think that anyone if they're just 100
honest is gonna be interesting on film I
think some people even if they are
maybe not 100 present in the scene can
still be dynamic on you know Russell
Crowe can Grumble any line out and
you're like that sounded amazing yeah
yeah check moving on that's right
and so it's look it's it's always tough
to question what you are and what your
strengths and weaknesses might be but
but I don't know if I'm one of those
actors that can just do nothing
and hold the audience you know what I
mean I think I'm better when I'm
actively alive actively kind of
participating in the emotions in a more
honest way there's probably more akin to
my natural nature so it comes across as
more truthful yeah um but I'm certainly
envious of those actors that just have
the
the the capacity the downies the
Scarlets that can just sit and exist and
you just like I'll watch a whole movie
of this we Val had never seen that's my
wife had never seen No Country for Old
Men for a good reason she was like it
came out at the same time as There Will
Be Blood and it's like you can't watch
two you had to pick one you know I mean
it's like you had like especially women
I think were like I'll do one
like like we couldn't wait to see both
but she's gonna do one and I'm with you
I watched Tommy Lee Jones and I'm like
God damn it there's a scene well he's
just sitting in a chair and decides to
get up and I'm like old homes he does
that it gets cut I mean you know what I
mean Tommy Lee does it so I'm so with
you and again I think this is why you're
in that fold of Comedy for me is it's a
better and funnier and more electric and
maybe more honest place where I stand
there and I I look at other people even
other comedians I go they just have
something that you just can't take your
eyes off and I secretly or maybe not
secret I'm telling you I don't think
that's me I think I have to put a little
judge on it I gotta do my homework I
gotta go out and I also like
do you do you I'm assuming you do I
think we all do like lift things like oh
that was that was interestingly the way
the we all kind of do Brad Pitt the way
he sits like when I watch succession and
and um uh the Culkin Rory Culkin
Kieran Culkin forgive me I'm sorry I was
thinking of Rory scoble anyway so Karen
is kind of moving I see some some pit
there I I see these moves that we learn
and and people like you and me I'm this
is the question we're going around going
oh that's how you do it that's how you
add a little flavor well it's just funny
it's it's trying to drop into the what
what looks like reality what looks like
the truth sometimes it's a physical and
like
you know what it is you know what it is
I remember the first time I met Sean
Penn and he just like
he just like Ben was just himself he was
looking into my eyes it made me and he's
a paperweight he's a paperweight he's an
anchor he just moves through the world
in such a
centered way if all of the roles he
plays are funneled through that level of
just centeredness it's anything he does
in a still fashion is going to be
authentic because he lives in that place
all day I couldn't be more uh scattered
in a sense and so when I'm trying to
find truth it usually comes in the form
of a little bit of a scattered movement
it's almost like the way to practice
being a better actor is yeah practicing
being present in your daily life
practice discomfort of just Stillness of
actually making I I'm not a big eye
contact guy either I didn't know that
someone told me that recently that when
I'm talking I'm kind of all over the
place it's tough it's tough to just look
in someone's eyeballs
agree you probably should have you know
worked on in our youth but but trying to
do it now you recognize how much
discomfort you feel naturally when just
being yourself let alone trying to be
someone else in front of 100 people yes
I'm totally with you I met Sean Penn
briefly and it was that sort of
experience and that I think that's
actually what we're envying it's not
just their ability to act if I'm hearing
us correctly it's that they're like
grounded people they're centered people
and it seemed like you were very close
to saying I I would agree with this to
be a better actor be a better person to
be a better uh artist just be a better
person because Alan Watts had this great
thing where he talks about how children
are so authentic my daughter is so
captivating she's four and you you just
can't you take your eyes out off of her
because she's being real you see a
twinge of
melancholy and then and then joy and
it's all there it's just like all the
windows are open and then Alan Watts
makes this great Point like around seven
eight nine they realize how
um kind of adorable they are and then
they become nightmares like we all do
this the ego Creeps in I mean that's the
truth I mean yeah I mean God not to go
to Alan Watson but I mean I I love the
idea that
you know the the surrendering to the
moment whether it's in Life or in your
performance like it's to be comfortable
and to surrender to now because in now
is everything now holds everything it
holds the joy it holds the sadness it
holds all of it once you get to that
point of you know when your daughter
turns a certain age and all of a sudden
she can analyze the past and worry about
the future the now is hard to hang on to
and that's when all that that cocktail
of Truth starts becoming diluted with
the the the human uh
appetite oh yeah yeah you know and
control exactly can I make Sean Penn
isn't thinking can I make Chris think
I'm solid exactly that's that's not
that's like that's beneath him it's like
a waste of his time and right what a
liberating place to get to to try and I
think truly all art is probably better
from that place you know of course as
much as I can try and pour like a
technician's approach to Performance
when I break down a character and
understand on the day what I think I can
cut my cloth to technically it'll never
dive as deep as the person who says you
know what I'm just gonna let go and be
here right now and honest which I guess
is kind of what I was saying earlier
isn't enough but again this like
cyclical irreverose of analysis is what
keeps me out of the [__] moment
I think you're right though I I think
it's both we we can take
look you're on the right podcast if you
want to talk about Alan Watson ego and
and your true self and all that I think
our ego is a tool as artists we can look
at how we're being when we let our
instincts and analyze are we being as
authentic and as pure as it coming
through as cleanly as we want it to be
we can even add some judge and be like
that movement felt real some of us are
non-neurotypical I was just talking
about how Jerry Seinfeld who at one
point said he was on the Spectrum and
then he took it back because he's just
too famous to say something like that
and not catch a lot of heat but I I know
what he means I feel a little bit that
way and it's helpful to then what what
people on the Spectrum do is they
observe what is considered normal and
then they mimic it and by the way
neurotypical or not whatever that means
everyone's doing that everyone's going
like yeah maybe when when you sit like
evolutionarily when you sit with your
shoulders back and you let yourself be
vulnerable to attack but you're calm
that looks confident okay Wi-Fi fight it
Captain America can't can't go like this
he can't
that's just not how he's standing how
does he stand he stands confident and a
stand-up comedian can't stand like that
unless that's your thing you have to be
like I'm I'm not afraid so can it be
both can't we go easy on ourselves and
say the ego can analyze and this sounds
so stupid we'll learn how to be more
authentic and present through not being
present through analysis absolutely I
mean you couldn't have said that better
I actually think you guys being a
stand-up comedian that to me is just uh
there's probably I would rather do just
about anything in the world and if
someone said you had to try and you know
about 10 minutes on stage like it's
truly the most terrifying thing in the
world to me the fact that you guys have
the skin to do it and that your medium
is in such an immediate reaction yeah
what a crazy thing to do I appreciate
that but talking about what we're
talking about it forces you to be uh in
the moment and that's what I think we
unconsciously I consciously that's what
I like about it is you can't think about
the next joke you have but you did Lobby
hero that was one of the things I I
complimented you on I saw you on
Broadway with Michael Sarah and he did
um Lobby hero and it was incredible so
you know the feeling of the high wire
but the difference with that is like you
know you're obviously scripted and you
have this it's almost like you get into
this um I mean I did the play I grew up
doing theater and I haven't done it in
so long and I was like man I missed that
I want a new way into this I want to
kind of shake up the process and I
really thought it was going to get to a
point where
you knew the line so well that every
night you could try something completely
new and listen you know dedicate the the
biggest piece of pie to actually
listening and letting reactions take
over it I don't want to say it was the
opposite but in fact it becomes this
dance that if you kind of the song of it
that if you deviate from it you almost
lose your step you know what it almost
becomes this plan whereas I mean
comedians you guys you know the same
joke but you guys are ebbing and flowing
with every spike in deep Peak and Valley
of life I can see the point immediately
because if someone Goes Goofy in my show
I can go oh my [__] this got weird this
just got but you can't turn to the
audience but but again I'd rather have
mine at least there's a map you know
what I mean you you have to find a
counter punch as opposed to it's like
well they're not buying it but I know my
next line right hopefully save it
hopefully
I never went up that that would have
been you didn't it didn't happen no it
never happened I I have the actor's
nightmare all the time and I haven't
even done that much theater but I was on
a plane once with a guy who was in
Glengarry Glen Ross with Al Pacino and
Al Pacino is getting older as as we all
are but this was not that long ago and
he said whenever Al would touch his hair
and like mess with his hair you knew and
this was his line he said he's gonna
jump two pages
not not two lines he's gonna jump and
they they said that they would like jump
like it's it's kind of a whodunit
Glengarry so they would jump like
something that was essential to the plot
making sense so now they had to like
find a way to weave it back to do the
scene kind of again what a nightmare
nothing like that ever happened it never
got goofy no no not at all I was
actually just watching um clean Gary
Glenn Ross recently Ed Harris is in that
film right yeah he's so good I did this
thing I remember I I actually tested for
uh
uh Avatar back when they you know in in
2000 whatever like that
um but it was a weird process I I hadn't
actually auditioned for James it was uh
I was kind of the studios the studio
kind of I think it was Sam Worthington I
think it was Channing Tatum and the
studio kind of said and we like this kid
Chris so yeah I gotta test it so I had
to go down you're getting the full
parent makeup and you know I never
actually auditioned for James so you
feel kind of like you didn't deserve it
so I kind of wanted to know I wonder how
James likes his dialogue red
um and I've done this a bunch with other
uh films that I've worked on I think
it's very helpful if you
I played a lawyer once
um smooth talk and sharp Charming lawyer
uh and so I downloaded the script for A
Few Good Men
um which you know Tom Cruise is
phenomenal and I had seen the movie I
did the movie well but this is still
helpful any actor try this you download
the script you pull up the movie you
look at the scene you read the scene you
make your choices even if you kind of
remember the performance you still try
and make it subtle Nuance specific and
then you watch what they did and you can
go through the whole script pinballing
back and forth it's like you know
practicing basketball with Jordan I mean
you get to kind of watch what the grades
do
wow and I did this with uh the abyss
because I knew you know Ed Harris was
someone he had Chosen and I think that
role was a bit of a search too and Ed is
so good and effortless and just watching
scenes where there wasn't a whole lot to
do the dialogue was basic Ed just has
this way this is this speaks back to
what we were saying earlier just like an
innate an innate honesty Comfort truth
effortless delivery that some people
just have yeah
you would see the choice this is
brilliant I've never heard of this I'm
going to do this you're looking at the
page see I'm going to load this with
this thought too whenever I'm watching
an interesting actor they almost all
because I'm a writer too I write the
line how can how can you say that to me
that's how I'm saying it in the chair
and I'm telling you almost without
exception every great actor says it what
I would consider wrong I swear it's
always wrong there's some exceptions we
were just noticing that Billy crudup is
one of the most
um he does it simultaneously very
interesting and exactly what it should
be it's very rare but almost every actor
great actor would go like
how could you say that to me I'm not
saying they're Christopher Walken but
they don't
because I'm a stand-up too I want to
take the Audience by the hand and lead
them to the joke I want to tell them
little parentheses under every dialogue
exactly I have to go back and take those
out and underline things and italicize
things and but that's how comedians are
different from actors we go it would be
totally fine if I saw Neil Brennan at a
show and I go I would hit the word the
and he'd just be like thank you nobody
would be like I'm I'm in a character I'm
doing it from my heart they would go you
think that would be funnier but actors
are there to surprise you and to almost
get out of the way of the words does
that make sense honestly the tricky
thing is this is this Harkens back to
when I was auditioning you know you
realize when you go in to read for
something and there's words on a page we
misinterpret the words as
who the character like if we recorded
this which we will this this discussion
if if we were to put this in script
format
um and give it to someone who didn't
know either one of us would our words
really embody who we are I think on a
page right I mean they're they're
they're indicators but I think as actors
you end up becoming a little too before
as if they are and and I actually this
another thing similar to this I remember
a long time ago I auditioned for
Superman one of the old Superman's back
I think it was Mick G directing it or
something like that they didn't release
sides from the film
um it was a scene from an existing movie
uh I read the scene made my choices did
a little Google research found out it
was from a movie called Angel Eyes this
movie with Jennifer Lopez and Jim
Caviezel from the early 2000s or
something so I invented it before going
to my audition and do a little eating
um and watching what Jim Caviezel did
again just
lines that I made a meal out of he threw
away yes that's what I burned through
and you just realized this is a dance
that has no rules
I'm the magician and only I will the
next trick yeah and the words are these
things that you get chained to so
specifically in time of auditioning if
you can just
be different in a way that's still
honest that's still truthful there's
still accomplishes what the scene needs
that's going to separate you from the
pack and show that you know how to read
between the lines but right I've been on
sets before where
not going to name names but other actors
will read things in a way that you're
like
they're gonna do would like
the most basic line what the [__] is
going on yes and then it ends up being
[__] brilliant I don't know anymore I
don't know anymore or it doesn't
sometimes it doesn't you know that story
about I think it was Mark Wahlberg and
um Burt Reynolds and Burt Reynold there
was kind of like an alpha dog thing
going on on book and then you know the
story no but what a good movie I can't
wait for this story yeah it's a short
story too because I don't want to take
up too much of this this is great but he
was gonna do it Burt Reynolds was gonna
do it something absurd like he was not
absurd but he was going to do it in like
a Scottish accent and Paul Thomas
Anderson was terrified how because every
rehearsal he's doing this like very big
swing Scottish accent how do you tell
Burt Reynolds living legend don't do a
Scottish accent if it wasn't Scottish it
was something like that yeah first day
shooting with Wahlberg they haven't
rolled any film yet thank God and
because Paul is like what are we gonna
do this isn't working I don't like this
it's not what I want uh Burt Reynolds
and and Mark Wahlberg are kind of you
know they're the two Alphas on the set
so they're kind of watch watching each
other and uh Burt Reynolds sister
Wahlberg he goes you know I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do the whole thing in a
Scottish accent and Mark Wahlberg goes
that's hilarious you should really do
that and like that's what put an end to
it he just kind of assumed he would he
assumed obviously you're joking there's
no way
that's hilarious you should do that you
should do that and that was the end of
it and Paul Thomas Anderson The Story
Goes was like oh thank God he broke his
balls because it ended what could have
ruined the movie every time I watched
that movie I'm like he could have just
been doing a very different take maybe
it would have worked I don't know and
what a good movie too what a good
performance out of Mark Wahlberg I mean
yeah isn't that crazy sometimes when you
see performances you're like if that had
just come at a different time in their
career yeah
I completely agree yeah it was just too
new or something I don't know we love
giving Oscars to newbies yeah and like
that's not an easy role it's not an easy
role it goes through a real journey he
really does
in fact that's the risk of that movie is
it can it didn't but it could have in
other hand start to feel like an after
school special because he he gets on
drugs he loses everything and he starts
to cry and like it's like a it's
something they would show you in high
school they'd be like so don't go don't
do porn but they keep it they keep it
just outside of that
I couldn't enjoy that movie for the
longest time and Val taught me how to
enjoy that movie because so much of my
life I was watching movies and I
couldn't get into stories where the
characters were just making bad choices
I don't know if you can relate to that I
just go
yeah I was like stop it stop it when he
it breaks my heart like don't do cocaine
with Juliette Lewis don't you know I
think it's all going to explode and then
it does it's my again it's my ego going
like I'm not an idiot and she had to go
like you have to watch it like a fly on
the wall and go like this is just some
of the things that human beings do but
my ego would block it it's so
scared that it's stupid it can't even
watch a movie where someone else is
stupid without putting it down does that
make sense that makes perfect sense I
mean I I struggle now watching
I don't watch a lot of TV I don't watch
shows everyone wants everyone Breaking
Bad or no I don't want to do it
I'm out
I I finish it and I'm just like what the
[__] am I doing I gotta call my agent
like yeah you're feeling like bad about
your own choices professionally like I
used to I was just an audience member
before I got into this interview yeah I
know what you mean now it ends up being
a point of like anxiety and stress when
you watch something incredible and
moving and you're just like oh God what
am I doing and it's just trying to
separate those two things I love that
Chris just because
I remember Gene Hackman he was on Royal
Tenenbaums the set of Royal town just
two guys telling Hollywood stories but
it's fine Gene Hackman said so he's at
that point in his career talk about
Superman he's already been lexical he's
already done all these things and he was
on in Royal Tenenbaums and he told
somebody he was like
um before the phone rang for this I
thought I was never going to work again
and it was like it never it never
stopped yeah so I'm not trying to back
you into some confession I'm just saying
you're a human being like all of us
Marvel success
in this moment where is it it's just
something it's just a memory you know
what I mean your life is different
because but it's not here
what's here is just what's here with me
a human being that in this moment has
psychological spiritual social needs
that either are or aren't being met and
people think I think people think and
I'd love for you to speak on this that
you can go through any situation and and
like Seinfeld go like I was in game six
of the World Series you know it's or are
you in your case you go like
I was in the Winter Soldier or whatever
it was and that's going to fix your
problems would you speak to that yeah
sure I mean I I luckily I'm not someone
I mean I I speak about having anxiety
when I watch other projects but it's
pretty fleeting
um for the most part
I'm lucky in a sense I love what I do
but but but
I'm not one of those actors in maybe you
can tell from my work but I'm not one of
those guys that like needs it you know
and I like you know some of the actors
that like if they weren't an actor then
there is no plan B
um yeah I I love what I do but look
there's a lot of stuff that comes with
this industry you're aware of that and
it's it's sometimes it's challenging
it's not my favorite I'm not one I don't
you got to maintain perspective I don't
mean to sound complaining or anything
like that yeah yeah but but the bottom
line is I'm I'm incredibly content at
this stage in my life and so as a result
I don't feel this kind of uh nagging
burden or weight I even make that you
know the reference of getting anxiety
while watching other projects that's
kind of like maybe the me from before I
I slowly but surely I kind of feel it's
followed away whole to kind of
I mean I I
again I love what I do but I don't see
myself doing it forever I feel
you you have this great bit
where Utah I see it on Instagram all the
time because I told you I always want
you I know you pressed it two minutes
are littered with you I'm in the
algorithm now you think you're in
America zoom out you know what I mean
like I I am such a you know I'm big
space nut and just the vastness of
things and the yeah the scope the scale
the time the power all these things you
know makes you feel it once like you
know this surge of anxiety but then this
really incredible deep calm yeah so as a
result I I've been feeling just more and
more truly content truly where I am and
at peace and uh and I'm lucky too
because this industry is a real you know
treadmill yeah yeah constant carrot
chasing and and I don't feel that and I
don't feel that large in part because of
the macro perspective there you go when
you feel you're most stressed it's
because you made your words your world
small
um so the bigger you go the more I just
feel like it's just a miracle to be here
is it yeah it's just a miracle it's a
miracle to be here I was just get out of
my car the other day
and I got out of the car and I went
around the back of the car and then I
was like I wonder if I went around the
front of the car like think of the
sliding door ripple effect that that one
choice wouldn't happen and then I
thought about that for the next hour and
the the continuation of uh changes that
that choice that one choice is made has
affected innumerable like like and then
you think about every single person that
came before you your answers your
grandparents and great yes every single
day they had to make a front of the car
or back of the car choice or hit on your
great grandmother or don't hit on your
great-grandmother you know what I mean
like they they
happen to get you to even exist it's
like shooting a bullet with another
bullet it's it's a miracle it's an
absolute Miracle to even exist and and
that alone has really brought me a deep
deep sense of calm gratitude that's what
it is grateful that then you know
everything else kind of quiets now uh
God [__] a I love that I I also I I
was I went to Dave Batista's Instagram
if I'm being honest it was probably to
see if he follows me she's just too
embarrassing God bless you
that was I'm gonna have a vulnerability
hangover for that but I get curious I'm
flipping around and I'm like what's
David Batista doing and there he is and
oh he doesn't follow me and I just kind
of moved on but I looked at his uh
pictures and his arms are so big and
he's huge and and human beings are so
basic in that way I'm not putting us
down I'm just saying we can't get over
the big daddy the the guy that's just
like don't worry I can pick you up like
a baby and take you into safety I can
carry you out of a burning building like
we love it we're so it's it's so dear
how basic we are I mean I'm talking you
played a superhero you know the need the
the jungian need for dad's got you yeah
and all the superheroes are just
different moms and dads and so are the
presidents and so are everybody so
Batista is and I catch myself being
comforted like I'm like oh he's gonna
save me but then let's right it's stupid
but then you take Dave Batista put him
in the ocean put him in the ocean I
don't mean that to put them down let's
play Let's Play scale just here on Earth
put them in the ocean and look at them
from above and and zoom zoom zoom zoom
zoom where are his forearms this isn't
just Batista
Dave this Dave who does not follow me
this is not shots fired I'm just like
you're so locked in your human
perspective that you go I am this size
he is bigger but take him and put him in
the ocean if that doesn't do it keep
going look at the planet look at the
Blue Marble look at the and and again
not the reason I do it is for a a
spiritual connection to go like there's
a bigger
this is stupid and everything isn't
going to be literally true but there's
like a bigger power he's got muscles but
look at what we're a part of and don't
get too caught up in like because all of
that's no matter how much protein we
have it's gonna deteriorate so there has
to be a search for something
Eternal or or unborn or or whatever what
do you got what does that mean yeah I
could completely agree I mean if the
goal
I mean what's the goal if the goal in
life is a peace or happiness you know
what's the shortest the the the quickest
way there is to kind of be completely uh
surrendering to the moment and any
thought that kind of connects to
you know there's someone's physical
prowess or their body of work or all
these temporary and permanent things
that are actually man-made Concepts more
than anything else that's right that we
weave into a story which my daughter
can't do well that Sean Penn can't do
because
but that
uh you know
proclivity we we we we tell ourselves
what's the Chris story you know what I
mean how we're perceived but but all
this stuff look eventually Earth's gonna
go away even James Dean will be
forgotten the kind of stuff is here
forever and I think that's an incredibly
liberating thought yeah um and again
it's it's just a matter of what brings
you closer to peace and turning down
that kind of egoic brain noise my brain
noise is loud you know what I mean it's
it's my my ego exists and as a result
you know you
analyze the past you try and predict the
future but all these things we spread
our Consciousness way out as opposed to
just dropping into this moment which I
think is I mean the beauty is that
that's always available isn't it
it's always available right now is
always here if you want it yes and
everything is in it
um and I think when you start kind of
learning how to kind of quiet your mind
a little bit even Dave Bautista's arms
won't won't steal your piece
well going back to your contentment and
getting into the moment what are those
slots you can answer that in like
because people are interested everybody
of course is interested in peace and
contentment and Equanimity and quieting
our our voice are there routines that
you do are there are there um I almost
picture them like like The Sims like
those those bars you have to keep filled
how are you kind of maintaining your
garden of Peace like what is the routine
of that uh well certainly what helps I'm
a big nature guy and and living in
Massachusetts you get the seasons I like
kind of appreciating
how many things that have nothing to do
with me things that have been here long
long long before me and we'll be here
after you
I'm north of La so we look at the
mountain every day and I'm like I get to
see something that was here for
thousands of years before I was born
it'll be here for thousands of years
after I'm dead [__] great thank you
my father was big into that and when my
childhood he's still with us but but
when I was young my dad was just always
it's to be in awe of things if if you're
not in being in awe is is such a great
um
Catalyst great great great gasoline in
the engine for um just for for joy and
and staying present because there's just
so many things to be just completely
completely blown away by absolutely
blown away sometimes I can't believe
that we aren't all just walking around
with our Jaws on the floor or things
that are happening around us so
um I don't know for me like I said I I
feel
my advantage is that I'm in awe of
things I'm in awe of things I'm just
blown away by stuff and that's not
something I really have to work towards
and and and that awe really drops you
into the moment yeah
and there's some great books out there
have you ever read uh Bill Bryson's a
short history of nearly everything or
sapiens if you had sapiens I have it's
right there staring at me daring me to
read it yet oh my God is it so good it's
yeah so good I just like anything that
puts perspective The Human Experience
and the perspective it's so easy to
think that we're kind of the center of
it yeah we're all the leads of our own
story but yeah you realize that we are
human beings even just in terms of Earth
forget the universe Earth We're In
general yeah
it's gonna sound like I'm forcing this
but I I looked at my dog taking a poop
today and I was like my dog doesn't have
to wipe his butt if human beings are the
most if God loves us the most why am I
spending 45 minutes wiping my butt my
dog I looked at his hairy ass there
wasn't a dingle a dingle on it yeah
when he's out and solid all he eats dry
food and then avocado every once in a
while and he shits perfectly and I was
like even that Chris reminded me it's
not all about us Julius Sweeney made
that point
um she's she's a lovely atheist I'm not
an atheist but she made the point that
octopuses have way better eyes than
human beings do and she kind of used
that as a as an argument to be like what
we're saying human beings are not the
center of it I like to think of it as
it's like a tree we're one of the
branches on the tree but it's all one
tree that's why no matter how far you
zoom out or put Dave Batista in the
ocean Dave is the ocean and Dave is Dave
it's it's all kind of one thing but
that's where it's at it's not really
your as you said your your story whether
or not you're nailing it yeah a little
bit more brass tacks I just I think it's
because it's spring again human beings
are so darling and so predictable both
Val and I are getting like healthier and
just kind of being a little bit more
routine like we made up a schedule and
we were like I think we just need a
schedule because we have a four-year-old
this is when we're gonna exercise this
is when we're gonna meditate this is
when we're going to read even stuff like
that about a schedule I love a schedule
tell me yeah this is what I want a
little brass tax because
buddy I've told the story a million
times that's not true I've told him
maybe twice on the podcast but it's like
I've started doing cardio every morning
a bunch of people were like do cardio
not even for weight loss they're like
just psychological they say it's the
same effect as taking an antidepressant
so I do 20 minutes on the bike or 30
minutes just uh walking on a treadmill I
have to say this to you at an incline
okay
please edit this out I'm just kidding I
love it and since I've been doing that I
noticed that I get up in the morning and
a voice in my head routinely says what
are we going to worry about we need
something to worry about it's just so
routine that talk about gasoline it goes
we run on what we're worried about
relevance work uh do people like me
whatever it is all evolutionary stuff
sapiens would probably argue that's what
part of what's kept us alive is some
sort of dis-ease with reality what are
we going to eat in the winter sure but
since I was doing just 30 20 30 minutes
of cardio in the morning a new voice has
emerged that goes I go I need something
to worry about and I swear just louder
than that voice it went it was like
Matthew McConaughey it was like I'm
maybe we don't maybe we don't
maybe we don't and I was like how did
McConaughey get it
how did I install Connor hey it was a
[__] Peloton what the [__] I don't so
give me a little give me some of your
routine I I'm in not in a men's health
way it amends everything way God I mean
well the good thing is the
you were in provides wonderful
opportunity to practice you know and
like you're going to be in a constant
state of insecurity self-doubt time
awareness all these things that can
create egoic cycles and so you're given
plenty of chance to to kind of stretch
those you know present muscles one of
the things that I always do because my
anxiety kicks up at night you know
daytime I feel great I'll wake up I'm a
morning guy when I go to bed and it's so
strange because as a kid I love going to
bed it was but you know what as a kid it
was all uh egoic Daydreams about you
know being an actor and you know it's
all options it's all you know now now
you're in your life and you're trying to
keep the ball in the air and that's what
sparks all these
negative anxieties
um what I would do is just kind of say
you know what Chris
all right we're lying in bed look
there's nothing we can do right now
there's nothing to be done about this
there's no actual action I can take so
let's just um let's give her we'll go on
a little vacation all these problems
will be here tomorrow morning and we'll
tackle them all then I'm not trying to
walk away from them I'm not saying I
don't need to address these things but
let's just say how about for the next
six hours we just go on a vacation and
you rationally not like emotionally or
spiritually rap like you can you can
wrap your head around that and then when
you do you drift right off to sleep and
in the morning that little bit of like
kind of like that that kind of [__]
worked I wonder if I can apply that same
logic to this morning moment into this
evening's moment and then before you
know it you realize life can be just
that constant state of
obviously you want to be self-aware like
you said you know you have to
some analysis is to avoid past yes and
self-preservation that's fine but in
terms of like that real anxiety spiral
that has not useful it's just a matter
of saying you know what let's just go on
a little vacation from these thoughts
just for a minute just for a minute and
then just keep extending that minute
before you know it that's that's who you
are that's like when those thoughts
quiet down
we're not our thoughts are we our
thoughts are just this like [__]
noise in our head and nine times out of
ten it's not helpful yeah so yeah just
practicing talking your brain into the
practice of just being quiet you'll
start to inevitably realize this is
effective yes and it can be applied in a
lot more places I love the word vacation
I also I'm doing the same thing it's
like there's a higher self we could call
that's trying to reason with the mind
the brain you could say it's the mind
trying to reason with the brain or
whatever word you want it doesn't matter
you're going like like a child like a
Dad we're back to batistaing ourselves
you go like I hear you that's so much
better than shut up yeah I hear you
you're right what are we gonna do yeah
that's beautiful you care about us I see
you I see you caring about us thank you
so now you're greeting it with gratitude
but then you give it a gift you give it
a plan and you go like I'm just
recapping I I promise you if let's take
a little break I think we need a break
it's just like telling my daughter I
think we need a sandwich I think we need
to sit down whatever it might be and in
the morning we'll deal with it and the
crazy thing is is in the morning those
problems just don't you know without the
Shadows The Long Shadows behind them
what what were you even on about but I
love to see I'm hearing a little Eckhart
Tolle are you an Eckhart Tolle person
yeah major major huge huge he says 99 of
your thoughts are repetitive and useless
and uh the I think is right it's
attributed to ramdas a lot of people
have said I think but your mind is a
wonderful servant but a terrible Master
but no one is teaching us this we think
we are our thoughts when really what is
called the eye is the I could say the
field of awareness you could also say
it's the blank piece of paper that the
thoughts are written on it's the
constant it's the thing it's the space
in the spaciousness in which everything
appears right now you're a phenomenon in
my Consciousness where the sound of us
is a phenomenon and everyone that's
listening but that's not you that comes
and goes so what is constant what was
there when you were five that memory you
have of seeing a dead bird what was
there there was a sense of being that
was there and that doesn't age and
that's why when you talk to old people
Norman Lear did this podcast I was like
do you feel older dudes in his 90s he's
like no because he's he's checking his
awareness he's not even looking at his
body he goes I don't feel this is why we
don't feel older as we get we feel the
same because there is a part of us that
doesn't change and it's that Sky wherein
the clouds which are our thoughts our
feelings and our circumstance up here
but it sounds to me like we're agreeing
peace comes with Sky identification
instead of cloud identification 100 it's
like this site you have to
simultaneously
I mean the problem is by the time we're
able to be aware of Concepts like this
you might be in your late teens early
20s and you're pretty hardwired so you
already got to kind of rewrite this ship
we've been if if you were taught at 10
11 12 when you first start grappling
with these egoic struggles in your you
know school years it might be easier to
kind of um
correct the the you know unhealthy
habits but it's the type of thing where
when you get to those you know early 20s
years having some sort of little
practice that gives you a taste of the
moment and why it can be so good just
like I said saying I'm gonna go on
vacation at night just a little taste
that this works while simultaneously in
your Waking Life making sure you also
practice like you said the non you know
we go small we think we are a body we
think we're our thoughts going
recognizing the timelessness of things
nothing separate zoom out you know what
I mean you are not a separate thing
nothing exists alone you didn't just
come from your mom and your dad your mom
drank water your dad breathed air you
are that tree you are because of this
yeah it is the kind of constant
interconnectedness to everything Yes
actually helps reduce that egoic noise
because that comes from a selfish place
of I you know I mean you can kind of
bring that down through awareness of the
macro yes also showing that dropping
this compulsion to be you know anxious
also provides this like ocean of
Stillness it's kind of it's
it's such a hard thing to to reshape
specifically in this industry
specifically in a business that is
specifically in our culture right now I
mean we're we're bending in such a
dangerous Direction the in I mean I was
just saying this to someone the internet
this this
I think again not to go off on a real
strange tangent but at least inventions
that have affected mankind it probably
goes fire the internet the wheel like
the internet
the wheel is third folks like the
internet is and we don't even there's
just not enough yeah yeah to even kind
of draw a conclusion and and I I worry
that so much of it is about satisfying
that egoic appetite of oh of course it
is individual's story and I'll give you
the hope do you want a little hope I
love it my hope is
because I feel like to recognize that
you are an ego and that it's not working
that's the the basic spiritual precept
of all Traditions is you have an ego and
you have your true self and the ego
isn't working yeah I think the way Show
Business can do it I really think it can
and I think I really think it can I
don't know I said that like Trump
business can do it it's really great it
makes you see your ego it's so dumb why
does it come out like that I really
think it can Chris great guy captain of
the mic
um but I think social media can do it
because that emptiness when that
everyone now now I'm looking it as a
gift everyone gets to experience the
hollowness of a viral whatever that
means in your world a hundred likes in
junior high on a video or a post or
whatever or or a comment from a
celebrity and you see it doesn't work I
actually think this is a again from an
optimistic play
this shows the
Unstoppable the unstoppableness that
love is pursuing us that we are pursuing
ourselves that it will go I'll hide
behind a pile of [__]
so that when you eat all of it uh there
I'll be it's called falling up where it
is Richard or we don't come to God by
doing it wrong uh right we come to God
by doing it wrong you don't wake up from
dreams you wake up from nightmares there
it is yes it has to get bad enough to
break a cycle that's why I really do
think we're at a critical mass there is
like you know they say there's like a
god-shaped hole in in us right now you
know I think things were easier at a
time where religion I'm not by any means
like a deeply religious person but
certainly a spiritual one and back when
religion provided those answers and
purpose and you know we didn't know
where the sun went at night it was
almost easier to process our daily
struggle because we had an answer there
was a North star now I think people are
kind of feeling that god-shaped hole and
it's it's
like
like every animal
when I see like a turtle crack out of a
shell and he just knows to go to the
[__] ocean
this thing just came into existence and
it has a brain and it has Instinct we
say the words like instinct or jeans
well you've explained nothing yeah and
so so what's ours as a as a human what
what do we have and I think it's like
this innate
um
the kind of
awareness this like appreciation the
ability to kind of
be in this
you know bag of of skin that that
manifested in a way to express not just
love but an understanding of something
that is spiritual that's a beautiful
thing and it has to be satiated in order
to feel happy and whole right and I
think what people are looking for right
now is something like that this is why
but I wish
I wish with the art form that I chose to
pursue
um It's Tricky as an actor to find
projects that can you know if you're a
painter or something you can paint
something that actually reflects how
you're feeling of this particular issue
but as an actor it's hard to to come up
with with projects that you think can
help move that needle because I think I
think it's ripe you know I agree that
one documentary that one project that's
like why it's gonna give you hope you
know it's right it's it's like
performing
pardon the interruption weirdos I'm
going to let you in on a little secret
that's true I never used to wash my hair
I never ever ever ever use shampoo until
recently I was getting my wonderful
friend Kat who cuts my hair was like
Pete you have to clean your hair but I
didn't want to because whenever I used
regular shampoo it meant it was clean
sure but it also looked like [__] it
looked like dried out fluffy [__] for
two days unmanageable dried out thin
brittle hay on my head that I just
couldn't control and it looked terrible
and I just had to deal with that that
all changed when I found modern mammals
the only shampoo that's like a
non-shampoo that somehow cleans your
hair but leaves it perfect I'm not just
saying that it leaves it absolutely
perfect like a perfect hair day with
structure it's got that Wave It's got
some of that natural moisture staying in
your hair where you need it staying in
place and looking incredible after a
wash now my hair looks like how it used
to look when I would wait three four
five days after a normal shampoo for it
to come back to life to come back to
looking great now it looks great perfect
hair day after I spend six seconds with
it in the shower which is incredible my
hair regimen is now the opposite of what
it used to be I used to not wash it when
I wanted it to look perfect now I wash
it when I want it to look perfect before
a TV spot before I taped my special
before I just go on a date with Val when
I want it to look good now I use modern
mammals it is incredible over 40 000
guys have switched you gotta see the
reviews everybody's mind is being blown
I can't believe more people don't know
about it once you use it I'm hooked for
Life absolutely never going back and
it's a small punk rock Grassroots
company these are just regular guys who
are fed up with shampoo frying their
hair and set out to actually create new
products to wash your hair with new
shampoo Alternatives specifically for
guys they have bars which I love which
is a low lather fragrance free plastic
free way to do it or you can get bottles
it's like a magic gray mud that you run
into your hair and then rinse it out
it's not like a normal shampoo and
somehow it's like magic it leaves it
looking perfect every single time spend
six seconds a day and have perfect hair
I found out because I saw it on
Instagram and and then I reached out I
was like we gotta work together I am all
in go to Modern mammals.com use discount
code weird for free shipping that's
modern
m-a-m-m-a-l-s.com discount code weird
for free shipping you gotta check it out
for real it's blowing me away also we're
brought To Us by our friends at element
healthy hydration isn't just about
drinking water it's about drinking water
plus electrolytes which makes sense you
lose both water and sodium When you
sweat but both need to be replaced to
prevent muscle cramps headaches and
energy energy dips but most people are
only replacing water why because we're
always told just drink eight ounces of
water a day that's what that's basically
our water education turns out drinking
Beyond thirst is a bad idea it blood
electrolyte levels especially sodium
which can lead to headache low energy
cramps confusion or worse and the
solution to getting through your day or
your workout just feeling good with
proper hydration to optimize your body
and your mind isn't just to drink water
it's to drink water plus electrolytes so
enter drink lmnt we call it element but
it's the letters lmnt elements has
become a huge part of my daily wellness
program and part of my morning routine
that I legitimately look forward to I
start every morning with a big glass of
water and a packet of element I like
watermelon salt is my favorite flavor
mix it up and you're good to go no sugar
no artificial junk just electrolytes and
great taste they give you the right
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
for health performance and energy it
also tastes amazing and when I'm fasting
having an element helps Carry Me Through
those hours where you really want to eat
giving you some flavor and also giving
your body what it needs to support
itself for healthy fasting an element
came up with a fantastic offer for us
just go to
drinklmnt.com weird and use promo code
weird to get a free element sample pack
and you can try all their flavors with
any order when you order and if element
doesn't exceed your expectations they
have a no questions asked refund policy
you don't even need to send it back so
you have nothing to lose support your
body support the show go to drink
lmnt.com weird and get your free sample
pack with any purchase that's
drinklmnt.com weird try their chocolate
Salt and try it hot it's friggin
incredible and it makes me pee less at
night I don't know why something about
the sodium all right back to Chris Evans
I talked to him a monk in Santa Monica
this is years ago he's just on the
street handing out like food and I
talked to him briefly and he referenced
The Matrix and I was like how cool is
this this dude just the sentence that he
said was and you know years ago we
didn't have films like the Matrix he was
like grateful to The Matrix I I come
from the Christian uh I'm not that way
anyway you know I love Jesus let's not
get into that I just mean I was raised
in the fundamentalist church and I would
have only seen the violence or that Neo
and and Trinity have sex and you see
butts or whatever it is and I thought it
was just so beautiful that that there
wasn't that first of all and that there
was this appreciation for it I also like
I'm deeply envious of The Truman Show I
even think liar liar has something to
say I think uh Jim Carrey has picked
movies you know he's a spiritual guy
that he's finding those things out there
but I'm with you because
story is so much more effective you and
I talking about this like directly is
great yeah but when you have a movie
like Truman Show uh that goes like you
were you inherited so much when you were
born you didn't even know it that is
like a TV show that is like a and
Kristoff in that movie Ed Harris again
here he is he's not God he's like your
ego he's he's building a world he's like
an antichrist he he's telling you
something is real that isn't real and we
all have that and it's not a fake town
and a fake TV show but it is
Chris Evans you're important you're an
Avenger Pete you're uh you have a a a a
friend of ours that has a 12 year old
she I don't I've never logged into my
Tick Tock but she logged into my Tick
Tock and was like you have 300 000
followers and I was like this is all The
Truman Show and we all have to get in
our boats which is his biggest fear yeah
he falls off he drowns you have to die
this is all Joseph Campbell this is
great this is great to find the to
puncture the wall and you won't believe
it until what you were doing wasn't
working so hard it pushed you into it
past uh Joseph Campbell says the
treasure you want is in the cave you're
afraid to go look to every story for
other examples of this Star Wars
everything yeah yeah beautiful sorry I
just went on a a big tear oh that was
great though I mean you couldn't have
nailed it I mean that that was perfect
there has to be I'm not again I'm all
for buttering your bread but I I see
that in Marvel I I've talked before
about how Iron Man he has to go into a
cave I think he actually builds his ego
he builds like a shell and he has to
recognize that he can drop it and that's
that's Tony's art but um it's the same
thing I'm sure the reason these movies
resonate has have you ever had an
epiphany that Captain America is telling
a story that has some spiritual meaning
to you oh man
um and by the way feel free to skip this
is like a hundred thousand dollar
pyramid you can just go nah I don't
wanna I don't wanna um I don't know I I
mean I I look does he recognize a power
that was in him you know what I mean
doesn't he have an Awakening of sorts
yeah I mean I
yeah I suppose I've always identified
with Kappa someone that never really
gets quite
what he he
gonna say yeah enormous burden put on
him
um but something he chose and as a
result you have to kind of consider the
people that uh need him yes you know
there's sort of a Garden of Eden thing
I'm not trying to force it I'm really
trying to think it out with you there's
like what I like about the story of the
Garden of Eden which of course I don't
think is literally true is that there's
an election into it you you choose to
eat from the apple and it kicks you into
the into the messy world and there's
something going on with uh Steve Rogers
that he
it's almost like he gets a wish granted
and then it's like oh but guess what you
have all this other stuff we don't know
we don't even have to go into that [__]
who [__] cares man I was gonna say
one of your your co-stars um Scarlett
Johansson have you seen Lucy the movie
Lucy oh my God the final scene in Lucy I
die no good I think I should die before
reviewing I died I love it I I why
aren't we all no [__] why aren't we all
talking about Lucy like of course you've
seen Lucy like yeah it's it's beautiful
like just fighting in that the writing
is so good and it's what we've been
talking about here like you're part of a
thing you weren't born you didn't die
it's not just you and she's re and the
scene where she calls her mom I could
cry and she's like like she's she's
getting full access of her mind
and that's what happens when we're quiet
that's how that's what happens sometimes
you have that on psychedelics or some
other Transcendent experience like you
have access and you can remember the
taste of your mother's breast milk or
something and and you get overwhelmed
it's like what you were saying like the
two bullets yeah touching if we could
widen our perception you wouldn't wait
in line at Starbucks in quite the same
way and that's and that's what's so
powerful word um this is water the David
Foster Wallace commencement speech
obsessed oh you have I thought you were
going to say obsessed
I know it's just you know this is water
this is water it's that kind of just
adjusting the perspective going macro
recognizing well that's one of the
things I do when I when I'm thinking
about you were talking about how
interconnected we are and and you said
it so beautifully your dad breathe there
and your mom drank water and that became
you sometimes when I'm trying to
remember our interconnectivity i instead
of air I imagine it's water that that's
easier for us to picture we think air is
nothing but as I say in that bit air is
made of the same stuff that you're made
of yeah why aren't we talking about this
and these are just watching something on
black hole I'm a big space now yeah
black [__] hole a black hole with
gravity crushing crushing crushing
crushing iron down to the like yeah the
force the power that is out there these
things that work that are right now this
isn't like yeah yeah it's happening now
hypothetical it's proven these things
are going on the fact that it isn't the
number one thought on everyone's brain I
I literally think if you
if you took the exact conditions of our
society and culture our social norms and
you just kind of a few cosmetic changes
set it on another planet and and wrote a
script about it I think the notes would
be this is unbelievable there's no way
these people wouldn't constantly
question what the [__] is going on yes
yes go to work and they don't worry
about it no way unbelievable I I when
I'm in that for lack of a better term a
clear space you know like you just kind
of comment yourself and you turn off the
ego noise it seems so obvious to me the
the majesty and the Wonder and and the
the it's not just Mysteries
the beauty I guess we could say the
beauty and and what I really am not Pete
and his body in the sandwich but like
the
what you could call the spring the the
Rupert Spira I always quote this as do
you know Rupert Spira no oh you got to
check them out I'll send you a link he's
so great he talks so cleanly about the
phenomenon of awareness he strips it of
so much he's like Eckhart in that way
and he goes we are the screen
like what we are
so he goes you have an experience and
there's something that's aware of that
experience and you are that thing that's
aware and he Likens it to a movie screen
and there's things that happen on the
movie screen but the screen itself is
never tainted or died or changed and
identify with that screen
I I don't even know why I brought that
up I couldn't agree more I mean come on
my dog is such a good little teacher my
dog will sit out in the yard
not lying down not relaxing sitting up
sitting up but just just an active
participant in his presence yeah and
just absorbing he's not worried about
yesterday he's not worried about
tomorrow he's just he fits he fits in a
way that I don't a lawfully unfolding
dog he's just being a perfect dog he's a
part of it and the reason he's a part of
it is because he doesn't know and one of
the beautiful things about human beings
is that we get born into this suffering
of awareness and afforded the
opportunity to let it go this thing that
we think makes us Divine and separate
and Superior is actually our biggest
shackle and we get the chance to
actually shed it and go back to him you
know he's the teacher yeah yeah yeah
right there's there's this just all
around us this beautiful Stillness this
lack of self-awareness that makes it
magical that's right magical yeah or
thoughts arise that moment before the
analysis of the moment that's who you
are right stay there and in the pursuit
you just reminded me it's like I pursue
all this specialness even even spiritual
Pursuits can be to be special it's like
I want God to recognize me I want to
feel good I want to be saved I want to
be enlightened I want to be this I want
to be that and the deeper I go into it
it goes like welcome I'm glad you chased
that carrot I has nothing to do with you
okay
I'll give you it has everything to do
with you in a sense but it has nothing
to do with you so again it's hidden even
that it's so it's not just the ego
doesn't work it's like even my spiritual
earnestness doesn't inevitably work and
there's a surrender and a melting and a
zooming out that just goes like Oh but
everybody I was just saying this to Neil
bread and I was like isn't it beautiful
that everybody the worst person
calm them down take the worst person
calm them down real in their body in
their mind whatever that means it could
massage rest nature Solitude peace
therapy just get them as calm as you can
and and then let them lull get them
breathing slowly rest their eyes incense
candles whatever it is at their core
that neutral St place that zero is Enya
no one is death metal at zero you bring
anyone down no one knows and I love
metal I'm not saying
I I sometimes get off the phone with my
parents and I put on metallic and I
blast it and I thank God that someone
has given that feeling expression I love
it but James Hetfield you bring him to
zero he's oh
you know what I mean isn't that
beautiful that's the word that's the
point everyone deep deep down in their
zero is clear spacious boundaryless
unborn undying unbothered peaceful
vulnerable and Invincible at the same
time isn't that beautiful and the beauty
is that it never
um
it doesn't miss like if you can get a
taste of it someone's not gonna get a
taste of it and be like nah that wasn't
that good like it everyone is gonna be
like that [__] was good yes I had it for
a second when I lost it but that was it
it never doesn't deliver that's how good
it is that's because it's it's what you
are I mean it's your natural state it's
it's you know yes it's so close yeah
it's it's the distanceless journey
that's why when we talk about all the
efforting we need to do to get there I'm
also like it's also just a stopping of
everything we're doing it's more of a
dropping and an unlearning are there to
tell me no go ahead I was just wondering
if there are moments maybe surprising
moments for me it would be in the middle
of a stand-up set I can get in that like
oh my God or have there been times in
your life that come to mind easily where
you're like tasting it
I mean I I
it's usually far away from my job yeah
yeah I wish it were more like yeah when
I'm on set you know it's not I'm
actually sad can I say I'm really glad
that you're not like someone's handing
me a latte because no matter how sweet
because you are a very centered person
and I'm really enjoying this and it just
makes me happy for you to see that
you're not drinking from a goblet or
something but no matter how humble or
small we try to be on set it is a an
amplified space someone is going to get
you a coffee it like you can't wipe your
own sweat away you can't you're wearing
gloves you know what I'm saying so like
that's not the Zone you're just so aware
of I directed a movie once and it was
just I remember
this this constant narrative in my mind
of just being like I need less of me
from the moment I wake up to the moment
when I go to something it's all about
I'm trying to direct this thing but
underneath all of it it's just [__]
me it's just me I'm just thinking about
me you know and and it's just I can't
[__] handle it and you know that's
just me it's me I'm just worried about
me here and like what do I do and how
are they gonna like this and what should
I yes yes
[__] exhausting and yeah people
you're trying to create even though
you're trying to make something bigger
than yourself it's still just you
um so yes that's right when I'm far away
from it you know I'm like I said I'm a
big nature guy Big Woods guy I'm camping
and I love driving cross country I love
the idea of just you know there's no
destination here it's just driving it's
just yeah I've listened to a billion
books on tape it's just
um I I think you know for me when I'm
far away from the industry and uh I like
being alone I'm a big alone guy you know
what I mean I'm an introvert as well you
know it's just kind of nice it's just
kind of like where you can really just
just yeah and that's when you realize
god what the [__] have I been carrying
to be so relieved right I'm alone Jesus
how you know that's The Truman Show how
many of us are going out like when you
visit your your family you remember oh
they hand you sides they hand you sides
there's everyone's and they my poor
parents they're playing them too they
also got a script and we all revert
everyone's doing that we know you know
how people have work voice you hear them
on their phone and they start talking a
different voice that's a character good
we're recognizing it so let's drop it
but what if like I'm so jealous of the
people that just have the balls to just
like if I actually move through the
world
exactly how I wanted to yeah people
would think I'm an [__] not that I
would be like without
yeah I'm not spitting on people but I
certainly wouldn't be up here I'd be
right be right down here and you know
but you wouldn't be dancing there's lots
of little dances we do where we ping
people like sonar and you have to Ping
it back in a certain way and this is
what I'm teaching my daughter how to do
and that's what's making me even more
aware of it I'm like oh when someone
says that it's nice to say this I'm like
again I'm teaching her her lines yeah
you love being alone because you don't
have to remember your [__] lines
That's it man that's it and and what if
you could be alone among people you know
what I mean well that's that's a courage
that it would require that's what I
think the beauty of getting old is
because you do stop giving [__] yeah
that's right yeah I don't care anymore
I'm just gonna do it that's right that's
that's some real peace were you in La
wait you don't live in L.A have you seen
Eckhart live I was just he just came
through no I haven't I I would you could
go up to New York because he goes to the
Omega Institute and that's this is so
it's like we're talking about a rock
band but that's like a little venue yeah
highly recommend because it's all about
that
when you're near someone there's that
Zen saying I didn't come to learn from
my teacher I came to or from the master
I came to watch him tie his shoes have
you heard that one no that's great isn't
that good just gives me the chills I'm
like that's it
and not to put down my tradition but we
were like can we be clean and bright and
and godly you know from the pulpit and
in the lobby these these guys are like
no it's about how you brush your teeth
it's how is how is Chris to his dog how
does he make a sandwich uh I'm as I'm
realizing I've gone over an hour because
it's okay like how are we rolling with
this imposition by the way how are you
on time should we rap no I'm good I got
about 15 more and then I got to bail
okay more
I heard that Boston
pick up it anyway go see Eckhart live
Let's do let's do the quickest speed
round I'm just so touched that you that
you agreed to do this of course man this
is awesome you're just such a good egg
man and a real talent so I I appreciate
it I won't bother you like ghosted I
want Cactus Emoji you but I will send
you uh some things that we've mentioned
uh if it comes up that I think you'll
like and please do the same yeah have
you ever seen a ghost
no I'm I'm not one disappointment no
yeah I'm not really a whole I mean
I I have a lot of dear friends family
members who believe in all those sorts
of things I I'm not sure look I I'm sure
there are my issue with ghosts are
can only humans be ghosts or can animals
be ghosts you just stole a bit from my
ACT where are all the ghost cows
mosquitoes like are they everywhere
what's their purpose and like what you
just did it you did what we're talking
about this is octopus size you're going
look you're only you're thinking only
human beings have souls only human
beings
yeah ghosts to me are a very egocentric
concept to me that doesn't track with
the the information we yeah I I
certainly look energy can't be created
or destroyed these are facts I I believe
in something bigger than myself there
are black holes there's magic going on
that I'll never know so I I'm sure there
is something but I don't think there is
an after world where you move like a
book from the [__] like or you know
or like I left that light off like I
don't know what he's doing
that just does interact with you I have
to get this candelabra from here to
there I just have to I know people
living there now but I have to do it you
know what he's going to hate turning
this upside down you know what I mean I
just don't think those are like the
rules of the ghost world but but you
know I'm sure there is
there's no denying there's something
going on that I don't know anything
about and maybe it has to do with
energies and look I know even like young
kids that
they say have more of they're more of
like uh vessels for right connectivity
between
past and future and I got it you know
what it is it's something that
it's like I don't need to believe in
gravity for it to affect my life it's
not in my business like whether there's
an after whether there's ghosts or it's
it's almost
it's not necessarily a helpful or useful
or applicable perspective to have and I
think in a weird way
it's a thought process that misused can
enforce ego a little bit yes kind of say
you know what ah it's it's I have no
opinion on it
that's very Buddhist I know you are are
you practicing Buddhist I mean I think
it's the closest religion to what I
would subscribe to but even Buddhism
through the years has so much Dogma
attached to it I try to stay away from
any sort of like dogmatic ISM I just
think the idea of a way of being yes you
know has a lot of I mean Buddhism taoism
Hinduism a lot of them have a lot of you
know overlaps so I think I can't lose
his sense of the word
um yeah yeah I guess I'm with you and
you're in a safe place I was gonna say
there's I I've quoted it many times but
a lot of things that are quoted to be
the Buddha aren't but here it comes
either way I love it either way
um it's like none won't be none right
what is it
no somebody said what happens after you
die to Buddha and Buddha said it's like
you've been shot in the leg with an
arrow
and you're saying you know who shot the
arrow yeah yeah I love them yeah it's
such a good one yeah just get the arrow
out just the arrow out just stop the
suffering yeah stop the suffering don't
worry about the origin exactly that's
exactly my perspective I think again
pulling on that thread I think is look
it's fun it's interesting it can create
wonderful conversations but I think
you've really got to be
self-aware because I think underneath it
you could be reinforcing this oh yeah
narrative that that could make other
things more tricky to stay present yeah
the ego snuck in through the back door
uh ever see a UFO
now that [__] I believe I've never seen
one but I mean
no it's it's Declassified it's happening
it's not even maybe you know what I mean
if you don't believe there's life out
there you you need to read a book yeah
that's the vastness you and I yes yes
the vastness of things it's not even
um maybe
I just saw the pilot that posted the
video of the cube there's just a cute
it's a [__] it looks like the Borg it
looks like the Borg's Cube but it's
small just Zips by a plane and I'm like
it's it's kind of like you were saying
about Wonder like or waiting in line at
Starbucks if we could really get in
touch with What's Happening Here would
be so overwhelmed and then even when
something in the macro like a flying
saucer goes by we still we're like
blocked it's like our brains block us
because it goes just just reproduce just
eat and and find somewhere safe to sleep
tonight and and it blocks us yeah yeah
um would you get in trouble if I ask you
this I I I I maybe that's silly to ask
but have you done psychedelics is that
something that's ever crossed you yeah
yeah I mean I'm I'm Pro uh psychedelics
I think there's something and it's great
that they're really kind of like being
the medical realm yes there is look life
is hard and there's a we don't always
have the tools to unpack some of our
trauma and I think there's been proof
that certain things can help uh
alleviate some of that suffering well
the last time I took MDMA a which was
recently I I had exactly what we're
talking about I was it was so much
easier for me not to appreciate the
Wonder of a tree although I could have
if I pointed it at a tree it's like a
superpower if I point at the tree but I
pointed it Inward and I found so much
love for myself and I was like that's
what therapy is therapy is a person
going Chris who cares who cares who
cares you're good you're okay you're
good and then this substance
it felt like 10 years of therapy again
I'm not telling everybody to go out and
do it this is just my experience and I
was like no wonder the the sign the
medical community is like this can help
people who have a lot who have been
given too many lines too many scripts
and now they can improvise more more
cleanly uh have you ever almost died
I've been in a couple car accidents real
bad playing turbulent things maybe
really you were gonna die but probably
oh no a couple car accidents but but
um you know nothing that's worth
no story like no no but you've been on a
plane where you're like this is the end
oh yeah oh yeah yeah it was oh my God
yeah commercial uh yeah and and and to a
point that you know not many dry eyes
people are you know shrieking and crying
and things are falling from the you know
it's it's and you just can't imagine
this plane can
survive this you know what I mean how
how is this possible what was it a storm
or yeah just really bad turbulence just
you know and and Relentless for like an
hour you know what I mean yes yeah
terrifying but you know I'm sure some
pilot would be like actually yeah yeah
you know so actually you're uh
statistically much safer than you would
be in a car it's like all right well
tell that to the [__] in my pants
which actually is on my paper have you
ever pooped your pants you don't have to
answer that no I will say I I mean I've
never I mean aside from my childhood I I
have very good bowel control you know
there you go
we're almost done here I had to ask
whenever I watch this is my one Captain
America I know it came up a little bit
but my one Captain America question and
I think you'll not have gotten this
before
is I always think when I watch like
winter soldier or something you wear a
ball cap and you ha Steve Rogers has an
incognito mode and his incognito mode is
the same mode you would do yeah at an
airport so you trying to be a celebrity
blending in at Logan looks like Captain
America and when it's only like every
time every time I watch that I'm like
what does he do I guess they [__] up
my disguise they like made the disguise
as recognizable man that was that one
thing of masks I'm still the only idiot
wearing masks I uh just at an airport
recently and I was the only [__] guy
wearing one yeah I don't care I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna ride that into the
ground just because you can't beat it
you can't beat it you can just move
anonymously even if everyone's like this
[__] [__] wearing a mask for well
that's Boston for you you wouldn't get
that in La you'd be there's still plenty
of us that's true but I'm not this isn't
the fame thing this isn't me checking if
Dave Batista follows me I like the
there's something it's like having a
blanket up to your nose or something
private and nice and then this is the
last question man
um we ask everybody
what is can you think of a time in your
life where you laughed really really
hard
um and it doesn't have to be a great
story The prompts I always give are
maybe someone fell maybe Mark Ruffalo
I'm just gonna maybe someone farted uh
meaning it can be dumb but if you're
laughing and tears are streaming down
your face how old are you where are you
and what happened I'm a big laugher I'm
a big laugher
um it's great and you know the idea of
trying to like suppress I mean like I
I'm an easy audience I laugh really hard
and I I find my I think I'm a very
joyful person so I my my friends say I'm
a real it's why I'm not funny I think
comedians don't always laugh at oh they
don't laugh it's a practice it's a
practice like I have to work at staying
elastic and and staying laughy yeah I
mean like I I just I think everything is
hilarious
um
especially when you know you shouldn't
be laughing yeah any church laughs
I had a press junk at once I did with uh
Hemsworth on one of the Avengers movies
where we were just you know getting
silly you're being bad we were just
making jokes and we couldn't
I couldn't stop he could get a little
bit better than I could he remembered
that you know he was here to be
professional but moments like that yeah
I kind of unravel and there's have you
seen Paul Rudd and um uh uh what's his
name he lives he's my neighbor Jason
Siegel Jason Siegel and Paul Rudd
they're promoting I love you man and
they won't stop laughing about farts
they just and the poor so people don't
know you're in a hotel room or somewhere
and they just keep rotating and press so
it is
supposed to melt a little bit you know
what I mean everyone gets five minutes
and so it's the same questions
quite literally 100 interviews you just
start going a little loopy and like
silly didn't seem funny and you know
you're being filmed and yes it adds to
this childlike urge to giggle yes I I
think that's a great answer and a
wonderful and I relate I've only done
that a couple times but it is absolutely
insistent I'm just looking at my notes
there's nothing I didn't miss I mean
this was awesome man again thank you for
doing it I it's funny you've never done
podcasts I looked I searched your name
in podcasts no podcasts no no and Europe
perfect podcast guest and people are
going to be blown away there's no I'm
just so happy to share this there's no
Chris Evans talking about the sky and
turning off your and taking a vacation
from your brain this is a gift you and
your dog and your friends the rest of
the day you feel good you did something
good you are a gift thank you so much
this was great my pleasure would you say
keep it crispy it's how we it's how we
close the guest says got it you got it
everybody keep it crispy you feel me
[Music]